[Musique]
gif et ira de médecins vétérinaires
miliciens enseignant à la faculté de
médecine vétérinaire est responsable de
la clinique des autres
croit on est présentement à
saint-hyacinthe c'est la clique répartis
du service de médecine zoologique de
l'hôpital et c'est là qu'on soigne des
autres croient trouver blessés ou
malades ou maniema aussi pour les
diagnostics à travers la province depuis
de 30,2 en une buse à queue rousse qui
est un oiseau sauvage qui étaient
trouvés et on ne fait les examens
physiques les soins de deux bases là
pour parce que l'eau était très faible
tant qu'il est arrivé maintenant est
assez fort pour faire une radiographie
pour affiner le diagnostic organes de
l'ensemble des réseaux c'est sûr que pas
de présence de plomb lorsque j'étais
étudiant
durant l'été juin travaille dans un
centre de recherche sur les autres
points et gerald dick avait pas d'
expertise vétérinaire à se centrer sur
les bancs d'école on apprenait pour
soins comment soigner l'épaule leading
et je me dis bon avec les autres joueurs
on pourra enseigner la médecine
vétérinaire individuelle des oiseaux et
puis bah c'est comme stimulant pour les
éditions de dire on va soigner une
espèce qu'on pourrait remettre en nature
de première année en hausse une
vingtaine d'oiseaux et l'année suivante
on a reçu 190 oiseaux dont qu'on réponde
à un besoin
les autres aussi des zozos noble c'est
les eaux qui attire beaucoup l'intérêt
déontologue du public
caritas et des oiseaux mal aimés et
encore des oiseaux de proie qui se font
tirer au fusil ta mauvaise perception de
ces moules au québec qui a trois espèces
sont menacées ou vulnérables
on a deux faucons pèlerins le pygargue à
tête blanche et l'aigle royal
je veux savoir qui était ce un jeu c'est
un site naturel pour recevoir 400 au zoo
près par année ce qui nous permet de
vivre c'est dans le fond des dons parce
qu'on était de charité viksna sauvage
des personnes qu'il est le même pour
dire je vais payer les soins que comme
un peu une partie de moi-même qui
s'envole avec toute l'énergie qu'on met
pour les rétablir
au début on présente un grand duc
d'amérique au point et un petit dit que
maculé ensuite on présente aussi un
faucon pèlerin c'est un oiseau qui était
gardé de façon illégale
c'est dans nos autres peut pas être
remis en liberté à cause de son
accoutumance se sont habitués à sion à
l'humain
et on a aussi des rubis noir du point de
vue scientifique on peut regarder
l'autre point comme une sentinelle de
l'environnement
c'est des inrocks sont au même niveau la
chaîne alimentaire que l'humain est bon
il ya plusieurs exemples le ddt
ça a été découvert sur des faucons
pèlerins il y avait un effet sur ces
reproductions leur fonte des neiges qui
est l'emblème aviaire du québec c'est
l'espèce le plus chassés légalement des
gens vont penser que bon c'est cet
oiseau qui est d'attaqué qui est
nuisible
cet oiseau la sonnerie dans un champ
l'hiver il peut manger facilement entre
trois et cinq mille euros par jour parce
que les autres os mobiles collectif où
je me sens privilégié d'être en contact
avec des oiseaux aussi noble